i heard after the game that they they
were referring to
to tom brady as the greatest of all time
and the goat and i thought it was
interesting that he has won
seven championships and i
have won seven championships there's
something incredibly comical about
blake comparing himself to tom brady
maybe the height that's about it
the length i mean all right blake and
nick
back at it again are you guys ready are
you excited how are we feeling
feeling good you know blake is in his
20th season which means that he's
just getting bored getting tired of
doing this and
uh you know this new blood me i mean
coming in and taking this crown it's
gonna be a lot of fun for me
welcome back thank you it's good to be
back i love nick jonas y'all
what's not to love he's a gentleman he's
very talented
very handsome nick jonas is sitting
there in a freshly
windexed jacket blake he just said
taking his crown are you letting this
young whippersnapper do that to you a
veteran of this show
lauren i don't know if you watched the
super bowl but uh
there was a young young kid named
patrick mahomes that
thought he was going to do that with tom
brady
and we know how that worked out i mean
and you know what's
strange too is is i was telling nick
earlier that i heard
i heard after the game that they they
were referring to
to tom brady as the greatest of all time
and
and i thought it was interesting that he
has won seven championships
and i have won seven championships
there's something incredibly comical
about
blake comparing himself to tom brady
it's just
you don't you don't see the the
similarities there nick
uh maybe the height that's about it
the length i mean model good looks
the goat unstoppable success
blake i i look let's reminisce on this
it is 20 seasons 10 years
i actually was at the very first press
day for the voice
a decade ago which is crazy like did you
ever think the show would be this
huge for this long i didn't i i didn't
know any show
could last this long you know it's like
i can't even believe this is still
happening
uh but you know it's the show is kind of
i feel like kind of crossed over into
a different a different place because
it's
almost it's become a part of people's
lives
in this in the way that you know other
shows like
wheel of fortune or prices right or
jeopardy or something where it's like
it's a part of their routine and yeah
and
and they can't imagine not having it you
know and and
will you ever not have it do you have
another 20 seasons in you probably not
i mean i can't imagine especially they
bring in these smart asses like nick
jonas you know i don't know how much
longer i can deal with
nick well you've got a little experience
now what are you going to do this season
to make sure you win
are you changing the strategy at all you
know i think
overall this is gonna sound probably
pretty stupid but it's just about having
fun
um when you take the competition side of
this too seriously as you're trying to
coach
you know your team members uh it puts a
lot of pressure on there that shouldn't
be there you know that this is meant to
be
an amazing journey for them you know
regardless of the outcome there's one
winner sure but the journey that we all
go on together collectively
is what really matters it's been you
know a little difficult uh on both these
seasons i've done them doing
because of obviously the the uh the
pandemic
um and we've had to find new ways to go
about
uh kind of these different rounds of the
show but i think
it was an all hands on deck approach
from everyone on the you know production
side and
um and all of us to make a show that has
all that heart
and fun that the non-pandemic version
has
and it's still gratifying as far as the
you know the
artist journey goes as well like you
mentioned the super bowl i saw that
super bowl commercial you did
with your fellow voice coaches adam and
gwen i mean
no what do you mean are you wearing
spurs
did you ride a horse here it was a
little mind-boggling to imagine a world
in which you might not have ever started
dating miss gwen stefani
i don't want to think about that i
couldn't agree more and it was
it's but at the same time people still
can't wrap their head
including me is still like how did this
i can't imagine it not happening but how
did this happen
because you know it's one of the great
mysteries of this planet let's be honest
it is i saw nick nodding on that
yeah well you guys both have some pretty
wonderful women in your life how much
did they help you with your team
you know blake obviously gwen has the
incredible experience she does a fellow
voice coach
she does not help me out because even
when she's not a coach
on that particular season i'm still the
competition you know it's
she comes back she comes back and and uh
and she doesn't want to have helped me
in
in any way because you know like nick
said you learn
we continue to learn from each other and
she doesn't want to
me to learn and he doesn't want you to
get the w
and now she has a w it's even worse
that is savage okay so you guys do not
talk about it she does not give you any
counsel
nope nope nick what about you does
priyanka help out
yeah that must be tough blake i feel
really bad for you there
yeah she does priyanka helps me out
because she's been a fan of the show
since it started
you know watching it over in india and
then when she came here
to the us you know die hard fan of the
show so she's
she's got a wealth of voice knowledge
that i have
pulled from at different points and then
once i get to the point where i build my
team
she's the first person uh you know that
i'm excited to share
who i got who picked me uh who picked
john or or
you know made the mistake of picking
blake or kelly um
you know she's she's the first one to
hear it all you know what i love that
do you have what's maybe the best piece
of advice you think she's given you
i mean i i think it it's related to a
show sure but she's got this great
ability in her life and
career to kind of go with the flow
something that i've i've had to learn to
do and and just
uh enjoy it and and so i think having
you know the home
base be that you know the the pressure's
off and just to be able to
kind of let my non-existent hair down um
has been has been nice
blake you're looking like you have
something to say about that do you want
to rival that any good piece of advice
you've gotten from gwen even though she
doesn't help
i actually had nick on mute that entire
time
priyanka is not a coach on the show and
so of course you know
they they coach together and i love that
you know i i have
i'm sleeping with the enemy here let's
just
place it that's you know this is what it
is
you have to navigate those waters yeah
yes it sounds like you guys are coming
out hard now you're past that
and all bets are off this season and i
didn't buy unlike nick i don't
i didn't go buy fake awards and to put
behind me
for the sake of this interview you know
i see over he's got two
he's got a fake bucket it does your it
does kind of look like an award but it's
just no it's
it's just and then the other two uh fake
mtv awards
well nick i we've gotta wrap with you
guys but nick i do have to ask you you
had told us
that a new jonas brothers album was on
the way
what's the status of that and if it's
coming could we see
you and your brothers perform on this
season of the voice where are things at
well there's always music being written
and and after the the year and a half
run we had we played 95 shows in 10
months
i think everyone was kind of ready for a
break we could not have anticipated the
break would be
as long as it's been uh because of all
the different factors
but i've stayed really creative and and
whether it's brothers stuff or or solo
stuff or joe doing dnce
we've kind of said as a rule that we can
do it all and it all just works
together so we'll see what the release
is i think what i'm saying without
saying too much is that there are other
things potentially in addition to
the things that we've spoken about
previously you want to announce it right
now nick
nick and i have a duet truck there now
yeah next month yeah
so new nick jonas album no it's the
duets album
blake and nick sing the hits oh good
that's a good name
i love that
you